on sera tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna à
360 voici les titres 1 le projet de loi
santé est soumis à l'approbation des
sénateurs le vote doit intervenir en fin
de journée mais pour l'heure une seconde
délibération a été demandé par la droite
sénatoriale sur l'allongement du délai
légal pour les interruptions volontaires
de grossesse vendredi l'amendement de la
socialiste laurence rossignol avait été
adopté contre l'avis du gouvernement
nous irons en sciences dans un instant
le sénat approuve rate il le discours de
politique générale d'edouard philippe la
haute assemblée est invité à se
prononcer sur la déclaration du
gouvernement jeudi une procédure rare
qui va pousser la majorité sénatoriale à
se positionner vis-à-vis des manuels
macron les explications à suivre la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est à suivre en direct et
en exclusivité sur notre antenne parmi
les thèmes cet après midi la situation d
urgence qui connaissent une véritable
crise alors que les syndicats tentent
d'élargir le mouvement de grève aux
hôpitaux publics
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir sur twitter avec le hashtag ses
mains 360 et pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera salle des
conférences ce thème traduit pour
l'érection des sénateurs à cette
actualité et puis alexandre poussa
depuis la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle dans notre multiplex tout de
suite
et justement prend tout de suite à la
direction de l'hémicycle où je disais il
y à une seconde délibération qui était
demandée alexandre poussin sur
l'amendement de laurence rossignol
il concerne l'allongement du délai légal
pour les ivg
oui delphine et ce débat sur
l'allongement ou non du délai légal dit
végète en train de s'éterniser ici dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
alors il faut d'abord expliquer ce qui
s'est passé vendredi dernier puisque
vendredi dernier dans le cadre du projet
de loi santé le sénat a voté pour
l'allongement de douze à quatorze
semaines de ce délai légal pour réaliser
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'était une mesure proposée par la
sociale à la sénatrice socialiste
laurence rossignol
et elle a été votée à la surprise
générale par le sénat car les sénateurs
de droite qui était pourtant opposé à
cette mesure
eh bien ils étaient trop peu nombreux
dans l'hémicycle pour se poser opposée à
cet allongement du délai dit vg la
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn était
également opposée à cet allongement
ecoutez-la sur la question de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
je ne peut être suspecté d'aucune façon
chacun le sait je suis particulièrement
attaché à l'amélioration des droits
sexuels et reproductifs des femmes en
acceptant la seconde délibération
initiée par la commission des affaires
sociales
je veux réunir les conditions pour que
ce débat légitime et lieu dans le bon
cadre et en assurant l'ensemble des
échanges que l'importance du sujet
justifie cela ne peut pas être traité
dans ce projet de loi et dans les
conditions dans lesquelles le débat
c'est fait les sénateurs de droite avec
l'accord de la ministre de la santé ont
donc organisé une seconde délibération
sur cette mesure d'allongement du délai
diverger mais pour la gauche du sénat il
est vraiment urgence à allonger ce délai
de manière à éviter à ce que des femmes
françaises partent dans des pays
étrangers où le délai est plus long
écoutez la sénatrice communiste laurence
queen
nous avons parlé pendant une semaine
jusqu'à des heures extrêmement tardive
de l'organisation des soins sur notre
territoire
et quand il s'agit de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et d'un droit à
pas et il faut une loi qui serait un
meilleur véhicule législatives
mais cette seconde délibération a
vraiment enflammé l'hémicycle et a
ravivé un débat profond entre la droite
et la gauche du sénat un débat
bioéthique sur le droit à l'avortement
écoutez cet échange tendu entre le
sénateur les républicains alain houpert
et la socialiste monique lubin je ne
vais pas intervenir en tant que sénateur
mais en tant que praticien radiologue
échographistes j'ai aidé beaucoup de
femmes qui étaient dans un projet de
l'interruption de grossesse
j'étais à côté d'eux j'ai ressenti leur
douleur à 12 semaines
c'est un embryon qui mesure 6 5 cm de
distance cranio caudal où l'on ne voit
que le bourgeon germinal à 14 semaines
nous sommes face un foetus ou nous avons
99% de chances de dépister le sexe est
là nous rentrons dans un risque
d'eugénisme et de choix de l'enfant
ce que je viens d'entendre la dent la
parole d'un collègue certes qui parlait
en tant que médecins nous conforte
effectivement dans l'idée que si nous
relançons le débat eh bien ça sera loin
d'être gagnée pour les pro ivg que nous
sommes et je pense qu'un certain nombre
aujourd'hui sont capables de remettre en
question ce qui est un droit fondamental
et que au détour de n'importe quelle loi
ne laisseront jamais brocardé alors pour
le moment cette seconde délibération se
poursuit et le vote devrait avoir lieu
dans quelques minutes
merci à vous alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions et cette seconde délibération
décale le vote du projet de loi santé
qui doit intervenir dans la journée
le jour où la crise des urgences
connaître un nouveau tournant
les syndicats les scènes en effet
d'élargir le mou
mon de grève aux hôpitaux à l'eysée
boissin la crise s'enlise
après des mois de mobilisation 95
services d'urgence sont actuellement en
grève alors que les sénateurs votent le
projet de loi santé aujourd'hui le
personnel des hôpitaux dénonce une
coquille vide du côté de la commission
des affaires sociales on estime qu'il
faut encore être patient pour voir les
résultats de ce projet de loi il va y
répondre mais pas tout de suite parce
qu'il faut le temps d'organisation
alors ça répond en amont mais ça répond
pas à laval parce que vous savez très
bien que aux urgences le problème des
lits d'aval est une problématique qu'on
n'arrive pas à régler depuis quelques
années le sénateur les républicains rené
paul savary craint que la situation aux
urgences de perdure il ce même avec le
projet de loi c-2 l'impression que l'on
a c'est que et effectivement toutes les
mesures n'ont pas forcément été prise
par rapport à ces difficultés qui doit
déjà d'un certain nombre de mois et je
ne suis pas sûr que si les mesures que
nous avons proposées ne sont pas pris en
compte que ces poids santé règlera les
problèmes d urgence autre problème
souligné par l'opposition sénatoriale
l'absence de financement cette loi est
donc c'est une loi d'organisation une
loi cadre d'organisation qui ne portent
aucune mesure financière ne peut pas
envisager que notre système de santé
soit totalement réformé sans des moyens
nouveaux
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'ils soient
réformées avec des personnels qui
aujourd'hui sont en berne out as pas
possible après le vote du projet de loi
santé les urgentistes devront attendre
l'automne lors du vote sur le
financement du système de santé pour
peut-être espérer des réponses à leur
ras-le-bol et dans le reste de
l'actualité politique valérie rabault la
présidente du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale était l'invité de
notre matinale
après le mauvais score des socialistes
aux européennes elle semble prendre ses
distances avec olivier faure le premier
secrétaire et goûter
fait exceptionnel en février 2019 la
cour des comptes a publié son rapport
comme elle le fait chaque année mais la
fin est un gros chapitre à écrire un
gros chapitre sur les urgences les
services d'urgence qu'est ce qu'elle dit
dans ce chapitre elle dit il faut
augmenter de 20%
le personnel soignant les médecins
urgentistes
c'est la cour des comptes qui le dit
vous savez qu'il est en augmentation la
par rapport aux années précédentes
actuellement oui mais pas de 20% là on
dit en augmentation la route
donc nous nous demandons qui est 500
millions d'euros mis sur la table pour
que ces services d'urgence puissent
avoir une réponse mais immédiate et
c'est pas en attendant la ministre de la
santé et des solidarités a demandé un
nouveau rapport c'est pas avec un
nouveau rapport qu'on apporte une
réponse
c'est donc demain qu edouard philippe
prononcera son discours de politique
générale devant les députés au sénat ce
sera jeudi matin édition spéciale sur
notre antenne dès 9 heures et vous allez
voir c'est une procédure rarement
utilisée est méconnu l'article 49 4 de
la constitution qui permet au
gouvernement de demander le vote du
sénat sur une déclaration de politique
générale les explications de flora
sauvage c'est une première dans un sénat
contrôlé par l'opposition
la déclaration du premier ministre
devant les sénateurs jeudi sera suivi
d'un vote
selon l'article 49 4 de la constitution
le gouvernement a demandé l'approbation
du sénat sur sa déclaration de politique
générale mais un vote négatif
n'entraînera pas la démission du
gouvernement
contrairement au vote des députés avec
cette deuxième déclaration de politique
générale
edouard philippe veut lancer l'acte ii
du quinquennat le premier ministre
détaillera la méthode pour mener ses
réformes
puis l'agenda au menu de l'exécutif la
réforme de l'assurance chômage des
retraites de la dépendance de la loi de
bioéthique avec notamment la pma et la
réforme des institutions pour le volet
constitutionnel le gouvernement va
devoir compter sur le soutien d'une
partie de la chambre haute et en faisant
voter les sénateurs sur sa déclaration
de politique générale
edouard philippe pousse le sénat à
majorité de droite a clarifié sa
position vis-à-vis des manuels macron
opposition nette abstention ou soutien
constructif
elle est la question voilà cette
question va la poser à notre invité
emmanuel capus sénateurs à les
indépendants de maine-et-loire on voit
qu'avec ce discours de politique
générale c'est finalement l'entrée en
dans l'acte 2 du quinquennat pour
edouard philippe
est ce que vous vous allez voter pour ce
discours on vient d'expliquer devra donc
un vote jeudi matin c'est la voilà c'est
extrêmement difficile de dire ce qu'on
va voter sur un texte avant de le
connaître puisque je ne sais pas ce que
veut dire le premier ministre par
définition donc aujourd'hui c'est juste
potentiellement ce que je pourrais voter
l'état d'esprit dans lequel moi je suis
je suis dans l'état d'esprit de plus tôt
avoir confiance dans ce que va sans
doute annoncer edouard philippe donc moi
je voterai la confiance oui
qu'en attendez-vous justement quels sont
les chantiers prioritaires rendre à ce
que je certains justement ce que
j'attends ce que je craignais de la
crise des gilet jaune c'est que le
gouvernement s'arrête et qu'on arrête
les réformes qui sont nécessaires je
crois comprendre et le vote important
d'abord la mobilisation aux élections
européennes puis le score qu'a fait la
liste des naissances donne deux
légitimités je pense au gouvernement
pour engager l'acte 2 de ce gouvernement
de ceux de ce quinquennat et poursuivre
les réformes pour ne pas dire les
amplifier donc évidemment sur la réforme
des retraites sur la réforme de la
fonction publique sur la baisse des
dépenses publiques
nous ce qu'on attend chez les
indépendants en particulier
c'est vraiment une poursuite importante
des réformes notamment la révision
constitutionnelle on sait que ça fera
aussi partie injustement du calendrier
le parlementaire dans les prochains mois
une réforme constitutionnelle c'est
moins prioritaires selon nous nous ce
qu'on espère c'est qu'il y aura un
accord entre le président larcher entre
les sénateurs et le gouvernement et le
président de la république pour trouver
un juste équilibre
alors on va continuer emmanuel capus cet
entretien montbetonais salle des
conférences pour une réaction avec le
président de la commission des lois tam
trân huu vous êtes avec philippe bas en
10 s est une procédure extrêmement rare
de la part du gouvernement de demander
un vote
à l'issue de la déclaration de politique
générale du gouvernement au sénat
effectivement philippe bas comment
interprétez vous le fait qu'il y ait un
vote jeudi au sénat à l'issue du débat
qui va lui même suivre le discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
c'est rare et c'est à la demande du
gouvernement
bien sûr c'est une décision qui lui
appartient et vous savez à la différence
de ce qui se passe pour l'assemblée
nationale le vote du sénat s'il doit
être négatif n'entraîne pas la chute du
gouvernement
c'est donc c'est donc si vous voulez
responsable devant le cg c'est un vote
sans risque donc il ya de la part du
gouvernement certainement une volonté
que le discours de premier ministre soit
suivie d'une prise de responsabilité
nous y sommes naturellement tout à fait
prêt étant entendu comme vous le savez
que le sénat ne fait jamais de chèque en
blanc mais que par ailleurs le sénat est
une assemblée qui ne fait jamais
d'obstruction vous l'avez vu depuis deux
ans pour tous ces textes de réformes qui
ont été adoptées par le sénat comme la
réforme du code du travail par exemple
pour vous les objectifs ce qui veut
derniers mois quand ils demandent ce
vote je ne suis pas le meilleur
spécialiste des attentions du
gouvernement il faut que vous lui
demandiez mai jusqu'il ya une
manipulation ce qui me concerne j'y vois
l'application stricte d'une disposition
constitutionnelle et je ne fait
nullement reprochent au gouvernement de
vouloir l'appliquer je me sens tout à
fait honoré d'avoir à me prononcer par
un vote étant entendu je vous le répète
que ce qui est important pour moi c'est
de dire qu'au fond certains voteront
pour
comme le groupe de la république en
marche d'autres voteront à coup sûr
contre certains s'abstiendront
mais de toute façon tous nous nous
retrouverons pour dire qu'aucun vote ne
se fait ici sur une déclaration de
politique générale qui vaudraient chèque
en blanc
elle ne veut pas dire oui à la révision
constitue avant tout vote qui se fait
sur la déclaration de politique générale
ne peut être interprété que comme un
vote indicatif nous garderons de toute
façon notre entière liberté sur les
textes et nous le ferons parce que c'est
notre adn de manière constructive
le sénat cherche à améliorer les
réformes il ne les entraves pas au
contraire ils essayent de les amplifier
dans l'intérêt de notre pays qui a été
quand même pendant les cinq années du
quinquennat de françois hollande marquée
par un immobilisme dont tout le monde
souhaite sortir sa faim poste au groupe
qui pourrait y avoir la moitié des
sénateurs et l'eire qui s'abstiennent si
c'est le cas
est ce que ce n'est pas le début de la
division celle là ce n'est pas le début
de l'implosion
d'ailleurs certainement espéré par
l'exécutif si ce vote avait une telle
importance les conséquences que vous en
tirez par anticipation pourrait être en
effet de ce genre mais c'est un vote
comme je vous le dit qui est purement
indicatifs et notre pratique nous c'est
en général de garder notre liberté de
vote comme nous la gardons sur
l'ensemble des textes qui sont ici
discuter parce que précisément nous ne
sommes pas nous imprégner de vision
idéologique des problèmes
nous sommes les élus des maires de
france la grande- constructive nous
sommes pragmatiques et réalistes et nous
cherchons dans l'intérêt du pays
le bon aboutissement de réformes encore
faut-il que ces réformes soient dignes
de ce nom c'est la droite constructive
où c'est la droite molle de n'autoriser
ainsi chacun avoir sa liberté de vote au
sein du groupe mais jamais au sénat nous
avons été dans des démarches
d'embrigadement d'endoctrinement de
caporalisation vous comprenez que ça
nous est complètement étranger et
d'ailleurs les français le savent bien
ils apprécient cette démarche
d'indépendance aujourd'hui le sénat dans
les institutions de la république et le
seul pouvoirs publics constitutionnels
libre indépendant et non-alignés et
regarder partout ailleurs vous avez un
président tout puissant un gouvernement
qui lui est subordonné une majorité
législative à l'assemblée nationale
qui fait ce que demande le gouvernement
le seul lieu où il ya du débat de la
discussion
une possibilité de marge de manoeuvre
une possibilité d'amélioration des
textes c'est le sénat et nous entendons
bien continuer dans cette pratique dans
l'unité de notre groupe qui je vous le
dis avec une totale certitude continuera
à se manifester sur le vote de tous les
textes l'actu au sénat aujourd'hui cette
deuxième délibération sur les vg cet
après midi le délai de recours à l'ivg
et g est ce que ça donne une image
rétrograde du sénat se débat qui a lieu
qu'en pense l'ancien ministre de la
santé très rapidement vous savez je suis
aussi l'un des plus proches
collaborateurs survivants de simone veil
et je n'aime pas du tout qu'on cherche à
cliver sur la question des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse parce que
jamais la loi veil n'aurait pu être
promulguée en france s'il n'y avait pas
eu un très large accord des français de
droite de gauche et du centre
et aujourd'hui c'est un grand acquis des
lois de la république je suis partisan
de préserver absolument son équilibre je
m'opposerai toujours à ces remises en
cause mais je me poserai aussi à ce
qu'on en fasse un instrument de clivages
politiciens et à ce que l'on réforme la
loi veil dans la plus totale
improvisation d'un débat qui n'était pas
du tout faits pour ça
bien merci beaucoup philippe adam a
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup merci à vous et âme pour
cette réaction emmanuel capus on entend
un philippe bas à dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'intentions cachées du gouvernement
pourtant on voit bien à la volonté de
l'exécutif aussi de demander finalement
par ce vote est bien choisissez votre
camp est ce que vous êtes pour la
politique d' emmanuel macron ou bien
vous passer chez l'ennemi au sénat ya
pas un suspense torride
ça va permettre de clarifier certaines
positions
ça c'est certain je pense que certains
vont pas hésiter à voter pour moi je
veux très pur si les réformes que j'ai
que j'espère sont annoncés demain je
voterai pour je pense que il le suspense
est assez limité parce que
président larcher avait quelqu'un
d'extrêmement malin je pense qu'ils
étaient il ya aussi une forte liberté de
vote dans cet hémicycle de telle sorte
que beaucoup de sénateurs républicains
vont sans doute s'abstenir de telle
sorte qu on va pas avoir un clivage très
flagrant les socialistes vont voter
contre les communistes aussi beaucoup au
centre dont je suis ont voté pour
ça permet effectivement de clarifier
certaines choses et beaucoup pour éviter
une explosion je pense du groupe
républicain où je pense qu'il ya une
détention sans doute assez forte pour
ceux qui veulent voter pour et ceux qui
veulent voter contre
il me semble que la position dominante
va sans doute être l'abstention chez les
républicains
alors est-ce qu'il ya néanmoins
peut-être cette tentation aussi de dire
vous me donnez bien finalement votre
accord sur cette déclaration de
politique générale ça vaut blanc seing
pour la révision constitutionnelle
non ça c'est vraiment deux choses
totalement différentes ce qui est
certain c'est que pour les gens de
droite comme moi c'est extrêmement
compliqué de refuser la confiance à un
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
est issu de nos rangs
kkm un certain nombre de ministres et
pas des moindres comme
gérald darmanin sébastien lecornu ono le
maire qui viennent de la droite et
refuser la confiance c'est quand même
extrêmement compliqué pas la réforme
constitutionnelle mais je lui ai dit
tout à l'heure
ce qui est important c'est qu'elle se
fasse de façon sereine en écoutant la
particularité du sénat alors justement
edouard philippe le chef de l'état
semble t'il va lui laisse un peu plus de
latitude de ce sera à lui donc et c'est
finalement le coût politique des
décisions après deux ans à deux
quinquennats acquis au chef de l'état ou
à edouard philippe edouard philippe ce
qui est sûr c'est que c'est une finale
et c'est très bien
certains ont dit qu'effectivement il
pouvait éventuellement être remis en
cause après les élections européennes si
elle se passait mal moi je le vois sur
le terrain dans ma circonscription qui
est une circonscription très centre
droit dans les bureaux de vote j'ai
présidé mon bureau de vote habituel
c'est sont des bureaux qui vote
traditionnellement à droite et qui ont
voté très massivement renaissance parce
que il y a je le crois une voix qui est
une voix modérée
on parlait de droite molle non une voix
modérée et je pense que les français en
tous les cas dans certaines régions de
france comme la mienne sont très
attachés à une forme de modération donc
oui je pense que la politique qui est
menée par edouard philippe
dans son style est dans son son convient
à une grande partie de la population on
voit bien journée le clivage la
recomposition politique qui s'opère
entre d'un côté finalement la république
en marche et de l'autre côté finalement
le rassemblement national oskar malgré
tout un espace politique notamment par
exemple pour le groupe les indépendances
vous représentez moi je crois qu'il ya
un espace politique qui est très
important c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi j'ai créé avec d'autres collègues
partis politiques qui s'appelle agir la
droite constructive parce qu'il y avait
énormément de gens qui ne se
reconnaissent absolument pas dans le
dans le renouveau dans le front national
dans le rassemblement et ce même dans sa
nouvelle composante dans son nouveau nom
et qui ne sont pas prêts à adhérer en
marche et qui sont en revanche
favorables à la réussite de ce
gouvernement
et ça c'est effectivement une marge très
importante et qu'ils n'ont pas supporté
qu'on tape systématiquement sur le
gouvernement
en arrivant à même d'aider etc c'est
invraisemblable
quand on voit des sénateurs ou les
députés qui s'allie à la gauche et l
extrême gauche contre les privatisations
là les électeurs y sont complètement
perdus c'est un c'est quelque chose qui
était qu aurait pu être dans notre
programme dans le programme de françois
fillon
donc là dessus je crois que les
européennes ont très clairement montré
des choses il y a la place pour une
droite et un centre droit si ce centre
droit et constructif et donc ça veut
dire et c'est la position plus largement
du groupe des indépendants dire quand ça
va bien il faut le dire
et quand ça va mal alerter c'est le rôle
du sénat c'est le rôle du groupe des
indépendants ici on parlait du discours
de politique générale d'edouard philippe
et des chantiers des réformes à venir on
sait qu'il y aura certainement aussi est
bien la question de la procréation
médicalement assistée qui sera parmi les
thèmes du calendrier parlementaire à
venir c'est un moyen aussi de donner des
garanties à gauche selon vous moi je
pense qu'effectivement je suis d'un
naturel plus sensible aux problématiques
économiques
il faut faire attention à ne pas donner
des gages à gauche pour donner des gages
à gauche
ce qu'il faut c'est tenir les
engagements de campagne le programme de
campagne et le programme de campagne
pour moi c'est d'abord la dépense et des
la baisse des dépenses publiques
d'abord la réforme des retraites d'abord
la réforme du chômage fin de l'assurance
chômage la réforme constitutionnelle
nous n'y sommes pas opposés à partir du
moment où ça faisait partie du programme
jégo faudra examiner ce qui est prévu au
titre de la réforme de la loi sur la
bioéthique par la révision des lois
toutes les questions sociétales il ya un
débat qui vient de se tenir dans
l'hémicycle avec cette seconde
délibération sur l'île et j'ai je vous
ferai sûrement on a le résultat du vote
on en faisant des plus avec alexandre
tout ça et oui les fines le sénat vient
de s'opposer à l'allongement de douze à
quatorze semaines du délai légal
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse 2
105 sénateurs ont voté pour la
suppression de cette mesure a ajouté
vendredi dernier par l'amendement de la
sénatrice laurence rossignol et la
gauche du sénat 102 sénateurs a maintenu
son vote en faveur de l'allongement donc
le cet après-midi le sénat s'est
profondément divisée sur cette mesure
pour la gauche il faut allonger ce délai
dit vg pour éviter que les femmes
françaises partent à l'étranger et du
côté de la droite du sénat et du
bern ots puisque la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn était également opposée à
cet allongement en expo on est con on
explique qu'une telle mesure ne peut pas
se prendre dans le projet de loi
d'organisation du système de santé et
par un petit amendement sans
concertation et on demande à ce que
cette mesure soit débattue dans un grand
texte bioéthique pourquoi pas dans le
projet de loi bioéthique du gouvernement
si beaucoup alexandre pour ces
précisions et tout de suite à leur
action de la sénatrice socialiste de la
loire atlantique michel meunier est avec
vous talent traduit effectivement michel
meunier votre réaction à cette adoption
très large contre bien l'amendement de
laurence rossignol qui avait pour
objectif d'étendre le délai trop court
ali vg de douze à quatorze semaines ce
n'est pas une surprise on non c'est sans
surprise et je dois dire que c'était
fait pour ça cette procédure
inhabituelle complètement
enfin oui très très inhabituel j'allais
dire inédite mais on nous a dit que non
c'était déjà passé par le passé en tout
cas moi je trouve que le signal est très
mauvais l'image du sénat encore une fois
va être écornée va être en dehors de la
réalité et réalité des femmes bien sûr
et du mouvement social autour de ce
droit à interrompre une grossesse
ajoutant que le gouvernement a accepté
cette seconde délibération dont l'issue
était écrite d'avancé cela le met lui
aussi face à ses responsabilités tout à
fait parce que je pense que le
gouvernement avait aussi la possibilité
éventuellement lui de prendre une telle
mesure dans la foulée du vote de
vendredi midi non c'est vraiment pas un
moment glorieux dans les histoires de du
sénat mais aussi du ce gouvernement on a
entendu aussi la colère 1 qu'il y avait
dans les rangs de la gauche autour de
l'utilisation du scrutin public une
façon de faire voter les absents
complètement et puis sur un sujet qui
est classique et traditionnelle sur le
droit des femmes et notamment de
disposer de ces grossesses et droit de
choisir
c'est quand même encore d'un autre âge
eh bien merci à beaucoup michel millet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et pour
votre réaction va tout de suite
rejoindre l'hémicycle où va commencer
bien la séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
si vous le voulez bien en votre nom à
tous mes chers collègues je tiens à
saluer la mémoire des sauveteurs de la
société nationale de sauvetage en mer
qui ont perdu la vie vendredi dernier au
large des sables d'olonne et emporté
jusqu'au sacrifice ultime l'honneur de
dévouement et de courage il s'appelait
yves chagnollaud alain guilbert et
dimitri bolik au nom du sénat tout
entier nous avons une pensée pour eux
pour la famille des disparus
mais ils pensaient aussi pour les
sauveteurs ton avis a été épargné pour
le sénat occasion d'exprimer sa
solidarité à tous ceux qui patron
matelots sauveteurs de la snsm 8000
bénévoles au service du sauvetage en mer
li 1000 bénévoles qui sont attentives
tant pour les professionnels que pour
les vacanciers présents toujours sur nos
côtes de métropole et d'outre-mer je
vous propose d'observer un moment de
recueillement
vous remercie
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
chacun sera attentif au temps et au
respect des uns et des autres je donne
immédiatement la parole au président
bruno retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain le président d'abord merci
monsieur le président gérard larcher
monsieur le premier ministre
toute la communauté humaine des gens de
mer comme on les appelle est en deuil
vendredi trois sauveteurs des sables
d'olonne trois bénévoles de la snsm ont
trouvé la mort ils se sont noyés en
tentant de porter secours un marin
pêcheur en détresse les circonstances du
drame sont désormais connus la mère
était totalement démontée mais
lorsqu'ils ont reçu le signal de
détresse relayé par le cross etel
ils ne se sont pas posé de questions ce
sont les mots qu'avec françois de rugy
nous avons entendu des rescapés ils
n'ont pas hésité ils y sont allés parce
que c'est leur mission ils existent sont
allés parce que c'est leur raison d'être
et même de mourir malheureusement dans
cette circonstance
depuis que cette terre et battue par la
marée sans fin de la vie et de la mort
tous ceux qui portent secours pour
sauver des vies savent qu'un jour ils
peuvent mourir pour eux rien n'a plus
d'importance que leur devoir et parfois
même le devoir
jusqu'à l'ultime sacrifice le président
de la république a décidé d'honorer ceux
qui sont morts je pense que nous
pourrions aussi honorer ceux qui restent
vivants parce que c'est le même courage
parce que c'est le même équipage
monsieur le premier ministre je
m'adresse à vous non pas en tant que
chef du gouvernement
je m'adresse à l'homme à celui qui a
art tient aussi à ce peuple de la mer
que je connais bien qui a été
merveilleusement décrit dans un ouvrage
qui a fait d'armes mark elder
je voudrais que vous preniez ici un
engagement un seul devant bien sûr le
sénat de la république mais aussi devant
ceux qui ne sont plus devant ceux qui
sont encore vivants je voudrais que vous
puissiez vous engager à tirer toutes les
leçons
dès lors que le moment de la décision
sera venu toutes les leçons de son drame
merci monsieur le premier ministre pour
vous répondre
la parole
[Applaudissements]
mais faire monsieur le premier ministre
edouard philippe monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président retailleau avant de vous
répondre je voudrais m'associer
évidemment aux propos que vous avez
tenus et que le président du sénat
gérard larcher vient de tenir pour dire
mon émotion ma reconnaissance
mon admiration aussi et la force des
pensées que j'adresse à la famille aux
familles des victimes
à tous ceux qui se sont engagés avec eux
dans cette formidable aventure que le
sauvetage en mer et à tous ceux qui ont
été incroyablement frappé ému par ce
drame vendredi dernier vous avez posé
monsieur le président retailleau avec
une émotion bien légitime
deux questions cette émotion c c'est
celle d'un responsable politique d'un
français d'un citoyen français qui sait
reconnaître des héros quand il les voit
et qui était mue par le sens du devoir
le courage dont font preuve des
concitoyens qui n'en attendent rien si
ce n'est le sentiment d'accomplir une
mission pour laquelle ils s'engagent et
votre émotion elle était je le crois je
le sais encore accrue par le fait que
vous connaissez la mer que vous êtes élu
d'un département où on sait ce que c'est
que la course au large
que l'on sait ce que c'est que la
difficulté de l'activité de marins
pêcheurs que l'on sait un département où
l'on sait que la mère donne beaucoup et
que parfois elle reprend et tous les
gens de mer tous ceux qui ont grandi
près de la mer tous ceux qui l'aiment
savent que rien n'est plus fort que les
éléments que lorsque que lorsque la
menace arrive lorsque le gros temps est
prévu il est raisonnable de ne pas
imaginer qu'on pourrait être plus fort
que les éléments et pourtant alors même
qu'on sait que les hommes ne sont jamais
plus fort que les éléments les
sauveteurs en mer sortent sans se poser
de questions alors même qu'ils savent
que c'est dangereux alors même qu'ils
savent que c'est trop dangereux
ils le font sans s'interroger nous
l'avons tous vu
dans des circonstances variées et nous
savons tous l'incroyable admiration dont
dont sont l'objet
c'est hommes et ces femmes en orange
comme on les appelle parfois une
admiration qui souvent passent par des
gestes ou des mots sympathiques qui leur
sont adressées par des dons par une
fidélité aussi à ce qu'il représente
je vais vous dire monsieur le président
retailleau que la république c'est
reconnaître des héros comme vous comme
nous tous lorsqu'elle en voit et je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait qu'elle sera
distingué à l'attention de l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens ceux qui ce jour ont
pris un risque en connaissance de cause
pour servir et pour sauver un marin je
vais vous dire également monsieur le
président retailleau que nous avons dans
le passé déjà accru l'effort et c'était
légitime mais c'était juste l'effort
budgétaire notamment que nous faisons à
destination de la snsm
je voudrais d'ailleurs attiré
l'attention de l'ensemble du sénat comme
de l'ensemble de la représentation
parlementaire sur le fait que nous avons
considérablement accru les sommes qui
sont donnés à la snsm met en valeur
absolue elles ne sont pas très
importantes
le modèle de sauvetage en mer tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui n'est pas un modèle
qui repose sur des très fortes dotations
budgétaires loin s'en faut il repose sur
le bénévolat y reposent sur les tons sur
le bénévolat complet et et nous devons
donc à la lumière de ce drame nous
interroger sur la permanence de ce
modèle vous savez monsieur le président
retailleau qu'en 2017 puis en 2018 j'ai
personnellement présidé le comité
interministériel de la mer d'abord à
brest en 2017 puis à dunkerque en 2018
j'ai l'intention de présider celui qui
se tiendra en 2019
je propose qu'à l'ordre du jour du
comité interministériel de la mer en
nous nous interrogions sur le modèle du
sauvetage en mer ce qu'il faut préserver
absolument
ces valeurs dans ses compétences est ce
qu'il faut réparer ou peut être
développée c'est une question qui
intéresse tous les gens mer mais au fond
c'est une question qui intéresse tous
ceux dans notre pays qu'ils savent qu'il
n'ya rien de plus beau que de servir ses
concitoyens et que l'engagement de ces
sauveteurs en mer c'est exactement cela
servir ses concitoyens
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole et madame annie guillon pour
le groupe de l'union centriste vous avez
la parole madame merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire une émotion
vives et sincères s'est emparée de la
ville des sables d'olonne de la vendée
et de la l'ensemble de la communauté
maritime le vendredi 7 juin alors que la
tempête miguel fait rage sept marins
expérimentés sauveteurs bénévoles de la
station snsm des sables d'olonne ont
fait naufrage à bord du canot tout temps
jack morisseau animé par la solidarité
des gens de mer
il allait porter assistance à un bateau
de pêche
des murs d'eau ont eu raison du cas note
qui s'est retourné une première fois une
seconde fois une troisième fois fatale
trois hommes sont morts quatre hommes
parviendront à rejoindre la côte dans
des conditions invraissemblables hier
quinze mille personnes leur ont rendu
hommage poignant un hommage poignant à
travers une marche silencieuse
ces hommes et ces femmes s'engagent
bénévolement pour sauver des vies ils
méritent notre respect ils sont
sauveteurs en mer pompiers membres de la
protection civile
ils remplissent des missions de service
public le canot jack morisseau était le
bateau de réserve de la station cette
embarcation de 1986 est sorti dans des
conditions de mer dantesque
parce que le cas notre numéro un est en
réparation depuis de nombreux mois
parce que l'association snsm et ses 8000
bénévoles subventionnés à 80% par des
dons n'a pas les moyens de renouveler
tout son matériel navigant monsieur le
ministre
j'en appelle à une nécessaire et urgente
prise de conscience collective afin de
taux de doter ces hommes et ces femmes
qui s'engagent pour les autres de moyens
financiers matériels suffisants pour que
soit préservée et consolider le statut
de bénévole et qu'un accompagnement d
à midi et des victimes soit assurée
excusez mon émotion
et puis ma chère collègue pour vous
répondre là par le cas monsieur le
ministre d'état
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice billon je crois que nous
partageons toutes et tous votre émotion
et comme vous le savez elles étaient
très fortes et très présentes lorsque
nous nous sommes retrouvés aux sables
d'olonne vendredi soir vendredi
après-midi après ce drame
à la station de sauvetage où je me suis
rendu et où étaient présents de nombreux
élus monsieur le président du groupe
l'est républicain sur retailleau vous
même le député stéphane du chou le
président du conseil départemental et
bien sûr le maire des sables d'olonne
je suis allée bien sûr présenter nos
condoléances aux familles des victimes
et aux proches il y avait il y as parmi
les familles des victimes des enfants
qui ont perdu leur père mais aussi aux
trois sauveteurs qui ont survécu et qui
était présent le quatrième était à
l'hôpital puisqu'il a été hospitalisé
après avoir été secourue je crois que il
n'aurait coûté que leur courage quand
ils sont partis en mer vendredi matin
ils ont aussi écouté je tiens à le
souligner leur sens du devoir
je crois que c'est important dans notre
époque de souligner celles et ceux qui
ont le sens du devoir et en plus quand
c'est de façon purement bénévole
je suis allé avec vous parler avec eux
et nous avons écouté longuement car il
avait envie de parler et circonstances
de ce drame et ils ont tenu à nous dire
que ils n'ont pas hésité un seul instant
il n'y a pas eu de débat entre eux sur
le fait de prendre la mer ce matin là
sur le fait
il n'y a pas eu de débat non plus entre
eux et les autorités du cross centre
régional opérationnel de secours et de
sauvetage
ils nous ont bien sûr ils nous ont dit
que la question qui pouvait être posée
qui devait être posé ensuite
c'est celle de savoir si on peut prendre
la mer il n'y a pas aujourd'hui la
moindre interdiction même lorsqu'il ya
une alerte météo sévères comme c'était
le cas vendredi dernier
par ailleurs ils nous ont demandé qu'il
y ait une table ronde qui soit fait pour
tirer tous les enseignements et bien sûr
l'engagement est pris de faire cela car
comme vient de le dire le premier
ministre leur rendre hommage
dans la durée c'est être à leurs côtés
dans la durée y compris par rapport aux
moyens qui sont alloués à la société
nationale de sauvetage en mer que ce
soit aux sables d'olonne où ailleurs
merci me suis vu ni zdk la parole avec
un autre collègue michel amiel pour le
groupe de la république en marche avait
la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
solidarités de la santé et portant sur
une question brûlante d'actualité je
veux parler de la situation d'urgence
madame la ministre cette situation aux
urgences en fait de surprendre personne
si les moyens alloués depuis quelques
années augmenter sensiblement le recours
des patients aux services d'urgences
augmenter encore bien davantage
bien souvent il s'agit plus de
consultations non programmées que de
véritables urgences
ainsi en période d'épidémie de grippe
mais il est vrai aussi que pour bon
nombre de français le service des
urgences est parfois le seul recours
possible
la suppression de la permanence des
soins en ambulatoire en 2003 n'a sans
doute rien arrangé mais on sait qu'il
est toujours difficile de revenir en
arrière
et puis ici le personnel des urgences et
au bord du burn out et maintien de vie
ne sont pas mieux lotis avec 50 à 60
heures de travail hebdomadaire or
permanence des soins
alors de grâce arrêtons de remonter les
soignants contre les soignants nous
sommes arrivés à une telle situation que
la ville comme l'hôpital
passez-moi la trivialité d'expression
rame sur la même galère hélas vous avez
hérité d'une situation catastrophique
personnellement je ne crois pas à
l'efficacité de la mesure d'un forfait
de rein et orientations car pour cela il
faudrait déjà une pré consultation pour
affirmer le caractère non urgents de
l'acte à effectuer et de surcroît cela
constituerait un manque à gagner pour
les urgences je rappelle que le coût
moyen pour l'assurance maladie et 250
euros quelle que soit la gravité
le sénat n'a d'ailleurs pas voté cette
mesure alors ayons l'humilité d'admettre
que nul ne possède la solution miracle
surtout disons le clairement à moyens
constants
certes les mesures que vous proposez
maison médicale de soins non programmés
hôpitaux de proximité apporteront des
solutions à moyen long terme mais à
court terme
que pouvez vous nous proposez pour vous
répondre à la parole est à madame la
ministre des solidarités de la santé va
là-bas nièce du zoo merci monsieur fait
dans mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur michel amiel la
souffrance des personnels dans les
urgences est une réalité
les difficultés de travail sont
anciennes elles se sont aggravées
le constat est clair il y a deux fois
plus de passages aux urgences on est
passé de 10 millions de passages dans
les années enfin des années 90 à 20
millions de passages aux urgences par an
et les services n'ont pas été
dimensionnée pour cela les conditions de
travail se sont aggravées j'ai souhaité
dès cette année encourager les
professionnels leur donner un signal en
redonnant du souffle à l'hôpital
notamment en dégelant d' en une fois les
crédits gelé en 2018 soit 415 millions
d'euros fin décembre 2018
j'ai rajouté 300 millions d'euros non
utilisés en 2018 que j'ai réalisé aux
hôpitaux en mars 2019 et j'ai augmenté
pour la première fois depuis dix ans les
tarifs hospitaliers non parce que les
gens payent mais ce que la sécurité
sociale rembourse aux hôpitaux pour leur
activité
c'est pour leur montrer que je suis à
leurs côtés en attendant la
réorganisation du système de santé qui
est l'objet de la loi qui va être
soumise au vote dans une heure
pour autant un certain nombre de mesures
d'urgence ont été annoncées lors du
congrès national les urgences jeudi
dernier d'abord une mission qui doit
m'aider à repenser les urgences pour
répondre aux enjeux du 21e siècle une
prime de risque que je souhaite
harmoniser à tous les professionnels des
urgences qui sont soumis à beaucoup
d'incivilités et une très grosse fatigue
une prime de coopération pour favoriser
les délégations de tâches entre les
professionnels de santé de façon à
fluidifier et éviter d accès trop long
aux urgences d attente trop longue en
permettant à des professionnels
paramédicaux de prescrire par exemple
des actes de radiologie ou de biais de
biologie et j'ai demandé aux agences
régionales de santé qu'elles allouent
des moyens supplémentaires dès qu'un
service d'urgence est en tension pour
leur permettre de recruter du personnel
voilà les mesures de court terme j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir d'ici la fin de
la semaine pour préciser exactement les
mesures la façon dont elles vont
s'appliquer je vous remercie
merci la parole comme notre collègue
josiane cost pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre la
transition écologique et solidaire les
lignes d'aménagement du territoire ne
représentent que 0,3 pour cent du trafic
des aéroports de paris
mais elles sont vitales pour certaines
des pelotes département enclave est
difficilement accessible par le rail ou
par la route afin de compenser le
déficit de ces lignes aériennes à côté
de la puissance publique les
collectivités financent de façon très
conséquente au maximum de leurs
possibilités
il va sans dire que la hausse des taxes
sur le kérosène hausse tout à fait
légitime au regard du réchauffement
climatique qui nous touche de plein
fouet à croître et encore le déficit de
ces lignes et risquerait de les mettre
en danger
on parle beaucoup de différenciation
dans les politiques publiques
territoriale c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi de réforme constitutionnelle
dans cette logique le kérosène utilisé
pour le fonctionnement de ces lignes ne
pourrait-il pas être détaxés afin de
permettre à nos territoires isolés de
maintenir leur activité économique est
de se développer
à défaut l'état ne pourrait-il pas
prendre à sa charge
le surcoût financier d'une mesure
extrêmement préjudiciable pour mais nos
territoires déjà fragilisé le rôle de
l'état est de protéger les plus faibles
afin de ne pas aggraver une fracture
territoriale que ne supportent plus nos
concitoyens
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le ministre
d'état me disent de la transition
écologique et solidaire veut la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice cost le gouvernement est bien
entendu favorables à ce que le transport
aérien contribue à la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
cela peut passer y compris bien sûr par
une forme de taxation environnementale
comme je les dis la semaine dernière en
réponse à une question du sénateur
jeunesse je rappelle que c'est au niveau
européen et international que doit se
mener ce combat
la taxation du kérosène haut niveau
franco français n'aurait aucun sens
puisque elle conduirait les conduit les
compagnies aériennes à faire le plein
dans les pays voisins à l'occasion de
leur rotation européenne il faut donc
avoir une approche qui soit équilibrée
et qui ne tiennent compte par ailleurs
je tiens à le dire je sais que ce n'est
pas la chose la plus populaire
actuellement en france
mais aujourd'hui le transport aérien en
france donc les vols intérieurs sont mis
à contribution par d'autres biais que la
taxation du kérosène faut donc tenir
compte de ce qu'on appelle les taxes
d'aéroport est par exemple certains de
certaines associations certains
responsables politiques il faut bien le
dire un peu par démagogie compare des
choses qui ne sont pas comparables
en suède par exemple et bien les taxes
d'aéroport représente à peine 30% du
prix du billet d'un vol intérieur quand
cela représente 50 % en france faut donc
mener ce combat
à l'échelle européenne et nous le ferons
le gouvernement porte l'ambition que la
nouvelle commission européenne et le
sujet de la taxation du kérosène à son
programme
nous avons une coalition de pays
ambitieux en la matière pour le faire à
l'échelle européen et ensuite à
l'échelle européenne se battre au niveau
mondial et enfin pour ce qui est des
lignes d'aménagement du territoire dont
vous avez parlé comme je les dis
la semaine dernière nous réaffirmons
notre soutien en regardant toujours
quelles sont les possibilités de
transport il y a en effet des liaisons
paris aurillac paris caste ou d'autres
qui ne sont pas compétitives en train et
donc il est logique qu'il y ait des
lésions aériennes et le gouvernement est
au rendez-vous y compris parfois pour
subventionner ces lignes d'aménagement
du territoire
je vous remercie madame cost si monsieur
le président on est absolument important
que ces données soient soutenus car sans
soutien
céline serait mise en danger et non
l'avenir de nos territoires seraient
considérablement assombri jour merci
merci la parole et à notre collègue
madame cathy apourceau poly pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologique
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités
depuis trois mois les services d'urgence
sont engagés dans un mouvement de grève
pour alerter la population et le
gouvernement sur les conditions
intolérables d'accueil et de prise en
charge des patients selon le collectif
interurbain ans 95 services d'urgence
sont actuellement en grève pour dénoncer
la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail et un manque de moyens mais
surtout la dégradation des soins offerts
aux patients
ce mouvement de grève est une
mobilisation d'intérêt général une
mobilisation au service de l'humain pour
la dignité
vous avez annoncé la création d'un
soutien financier aux établissements
confrontés à un surcroît d'activité et à
des afflux exceptionnel mais les
services d'urgence sont confrontés à
cette situation toute l'année madame la
ministre
qu'allez vous faire si le service
d'urgence du centre hospitalier de lens
ferme ses portes cet été comme le
craignent les personnels faire appel au
service de santé des armées comme l'a
évoqué le président de la fédération
hospitalière de france
qu'allez-vous faire madame la ministre
face à l'urgence sociale et sanitaire de
nos hôpitaux
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre
solidarité de la santé vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président les a menés
sur est ça la peur madame la sénatrice
cathy apourceau poly vous m'interpeller
à la fois sur un sujet particulier les
urgences de lens et vous le savez je
prépare tous les étés avant l'été comme
tous les hivers avant l'épidémie de
grippe
l'ensemble des professions de santé qui
vont être impactés par ces difficultés
estivale où divers pour justement
préparer la permanence des soins
cette réunion aura lieu comme chaque
année autour du 15 juin avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes et aucun hôpital
jamais n'a vu son service d'urgences
fermé en raison des congés d'été et donc
vous n'avez pas à vous inquiéter pour le
service des urgences de lens par
ailleurs vous m'interpeller sur les
difficultés des urgences je les dis les
urgences ont aujourd'hui le symptôme
d'un système de santé qui
dysfonctionnent à la fois en amont par
une difficulté d'accès aux soins de nos
concitoyens par le manque d'accès à des
soins non programmés et à la fois en
aval en raison d'une difficulté
d'organisation interne dans les hôpitaux
parfois nécessitant effectivement des
transferts de patients j'ai souhaité
régler le problème au fond
au delà des mesures d'urgence que je
viens d'annoncer en réponse à monsieur
amiel la loi que vous allez être amenés
à voter dans une heure et une loi qui
vise à restructurer notre système de
santé de façon à mieux structurer les
soins de ville pour faciliter l'accès à
des soins non programmés
c'est l'engagement de que prendront
notamment les professionnels de santé
qui feront partie d'une communauté
professionnelle territorial de santé
tous les citoyens qui seront couverts
par une cpts pourront accéder à cette
date des soins non programmés et les
professionnels de vie seront financés
pour cela cela devrait dégager du temps
en aval des urgences en amont des
urgences sur laval nous travaillons et
c'est la mission du professeur pierre
carli et du député thomas mais n'y est
que de me rendre un rapport sur la
refondation de notre organisation d
urgence pour voir comment dégager des
lits d'aval et comment faciliter
à l'avenir le travail des professionnels
de santé qui sont engagés auprès des
patients je vous remercie
merci oui madame la ministre je suis
inquiète et le bassin d'emploi où
j'habite dans lensois est inquiet et les
personnels sont inquiets et les pères et
les patients sont inquiet parce que il y
a et vous n'êtes pas sans le savoir
sept médecins sur 15 qui ont démissionné
des urgences madame la ministre
il y est il reste lui médecin aux
urgences
donc on se demande quand même comment
les urgences vont pouvoir de fonctionner
cet été avec sept médecins sur 15
déjà l'année passée en étant 15 il était
complètement débordé est complètement
saturé alors on se demande si cette
année avec 7 ça ira mieux qu'avec 15
voiliers faudrait peut-être nous
expliquer comment on peut faire mieux
avec beaucoup moins
et oui je vous interroge maintenant pour
que vous ayez le temps justement de
prendre des précautions pour que les
urgences soit ouverte cet été aux
conclure le banc au delà de ça je pense
que vous réfugiez vous refusez comme vos
prédécesseurs de sortir de la logique de
réduction des dépenses
alors qu'il y a non assistance et je le
dis au personnel en danger à poursuivre
les politiques d'austérité
la parole est à notre collègue jean
louis touraine pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain avait la parole
et merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des solidarités de la santé sur le texte
santé bernard jomier laurence rossignol
vous indiquer à quel point la situation
dans les services d'urgences est
désastreuse et à quel point les
solutions proposées seront de faible
effet 90 services d'urgence en grève des
personnels dévoué compétent mais
fatiguée usée souvent au bord des larmes
quand les admissions croise chaque année
jusqu'à atteindre 21 millions cette
année et ceci sans augmentation des
moyens au contraire près de 50% des
médecins ils sont des contractuels donc
précaire pourtant les signaux d'alarmé
n'ont pas manqué le décès de micheline à
lariboisière après 14 heures sur un
brancard n'était pas le moindre face à
cela vous n'êtes avare ni de
culpabilisation des grévistes qui
surchargerait leurs collègues mais ils
sont en grève parce que ils sont
surchargés toute l'année et qui en est
coupable ni d'affirmations sur votre
maîtrise de la situation
la réforme est de l'accès au soir
évoluerez révolutionnera notre système
de santé
la désertification médicale c'est
quasiment du passé la suppression du
numerus clausus la panacée miraculeuse
et j'en passe bref des incantations mais
la réalité les plus tôt la désespérance
que les personnels hospitaliers
expriment dans la rue face à l'obsession
aveugle de supprimer des postes partout
vous leur poserait sans doute que la
sécurité sociale annoncée en excédent
s'enfoncera dans un déficit qui pourrait
atteindre les 4 milliards 4,2 déficit à
qui la faute
d'où ma question en dehors des 700
millions que vous leur attribuez qui
sont pris sur les blocages de l'année
dernière quels moyens efficaces entendez
vous mettre en oeuvre pour ouvrir un
horizon plus souriant aux personnels
hospitaliers et aux français qui
majoritairement soutiennent leur
mouvement
madame la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités vous répond merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur touraine
je pense que appelé cette réforme
réforme est n'est pas digne il y a eu
une réforme en 2016 du système de santé
ça s'appelait le voie de transformation
loi d'organisation du système de santé
et à ma connaissance elle n'a pas laissé
des hôpitaux dans un meilleur état que
ne l'était cinq ans auparavant
donc je pense que tout le monde doit
être humble face aux difficultés
aujourd'hui à trouver des médecins avec
une démographie médicale catastrophique
et ce sont les décisions prises il ya
trente ans que nous payons aujourd'hui
donc avec humilité j'essaye de trouver
des solutions et la réforme que je fais
une réforme ambitieuse où je vais
demander aux professionnels de ville de
mieux s'organiser pour pouvoir partager
les tâches mieux coopérer autour des
patients chroniques de façon à dégager
du temps médical et à dégager justement
du temps pour les médecins urgentistes
afin qu'ils puissent se focaliser sur
les vraies urgences et pas forcément les
besoins de soins nombre non programmés
auxquels nos concitoyens ont des
difficultés d'accès donc soyons humbles
la réforme que je propose
elle est financée je viens de dégager je
les dis plus de 700 millions d'euros
pour l'hôpital avec une augmentation des
tarifs pour 2019 et j'ai demandé que
soit précisément fléché une partie des
budgets pour améliorer les conditions de
travail dans les services d'urgences et
notamment afin de les rénover beaucoup
d'entre eux sont beaucoup trop petit
pour accueillir le nombre de passages
beaucoup d'autres sont vétustes
cela accroît les difficultés des
soignants certains me diront on n'a pas
besoin simplement de repeindre vous ils
ont raison ce n'est pas simplement
repeindre les services mais c'est leur
donner des conditions d'accueil de nos
concitoyens plus digne et j'y veillerai
par ailleurs il y a des rêves des
mesures qui ont été proposées devant le
congrès national des urgences la semaine
dernière qui vise à donner des moyens
individuels
notamment des rémunérations
individuelles aux soignants qui sont
soumis à des rythmes difficile et à des
conditions de travail difficiles
c'est la prime de risque elle va être
elle va être harmonisés partout sur le
territoire pour que tous les soignants
aux urgences puissent en bénéficier
c'est l'une des mesures proposées il y
en a d'autres et je reviendrai dans le
détail sur leur mise en oeuvre d'ici la
fin de la semaine c'est ouais j'avais
quelques secondes places rogner lorsque
le budget est en équilibre grâce aux
efforts de la gauche pendant des années
maintenant qu'il est en équilibre
maintenant qu'il est en équilibre vous
puisé à pleines mains dans les caisses
de la sécurité sociale et vous n'avez
plus de moyens pour satisfaire les
besoins de l'hôpital
la parole est à notre collègue joël
guerriau pour le droff les indépendants
ils avaient la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le commerce
mondial est par des embargos des
sanctions commerciales qu'ils
s'appliquent à plus d'une trentaine de
pays des personnes morales et physiques
à des marchandises ou à des moyens de
transport les pays concernés voile en
économie affectée par ces mesures mais
ces sanctions pèsent lourdement sur nos
entreprises françaises travaillant à
l'international
le transport maritime en particulier est
lourdement touchée
l'environnement commercial devient de
plus en plus instable complexe pour les
opérateurs économiques en raison des
multiplications des cibles les sanctions
évolue très vite si vite même qu'un
bateau en pleine mer peut se trouvaient
immobilisés du jour au lendemain avec
des conséquences financières
considérables
l'armateur doit alors se séparer de la
cargaison mais aussi du navire pour
éviter des sanctions à son encontre
ainsi qu'à ses partenaires banquiers ou
assureur au quotidien nos entreprises
doivent s'assurer que leurs opérations
ne sont pas visé par de nouvelles
sanctions sans préavis
elle s'impose des règles et des
procédures strictes
ces procédures sont extrêmement lourdes
elles doivent se consacrer pendant des
heures à remplir des questionnaires
notamment sur l'historique des navires
ces conditions les amène trop souvent à
ne pas pouvoir honorer leur contrat du
fait
l'évolution rapide des régime d'embargo
et de sanctions sans préavis
nos entreprises sont exposées à un
risque permanent
comment peut-on simplifiée et stabiliser
leur environnement nos entrepreneurs se
sentent pris en otages par des décisions
du trésor américain qui se livrent à une
guerre commerciale non dit le
renforcement du pouvoir des autorités de
contrôle est considérable et le cas le
plus emblématique en la matière et celui
des décisions de l'ofac
monsieur ministre dans un contexte
commercial instable quelles mesures le
gouvernement compte entreprendre afin de
mieux protéger les activités et les
intérêts des armateurs et ainsi que des
groupes multinationaux français dont
l'activité est menacée par des sanctions
imprévisible merci pour vos réponses la
parole est à leur collègue jean baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur guerriau vous
parlez d'or et mon pour mot je n'ai rien
à retirer de votre question et nous nous
battons avec la même philosophie que la
vôtre avec nos collègues européens parce
que très clairement les états membres de
l'union européenne
eh bien ils ont un rendez vous majeur un
rendez vous avec l'exercice de leur
souveraineté économique
il n'est pas acceptable que nos alliés
nous dicte là où il est bon ou pas de
commercer pour les entrepreneurs
européens
et de ce point de vue là un certain
nombre de mesures ont été prises il ya
déjà une vingtaine d'années je pense aux
règlements de 1996 pour faire en sorte
que les mesures dites prise en
application de la loi n burton par les
états unis ne puisse pas trouver à
s'appliquer mais nous devons aller plus
loin encore aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs
nous l'avons fait en mettant en place un
outil l'outil in ce texte par exemple
pour permettre la poursuite du commerce
pour les entreprises qui le souhaitent
avec par exemple des électeurs iraniens
parce que naturellement il y à un
certain nombre de questions qui peuvent
se poser s'agissant est bien de l'
influence de ce pays mais la réponse
n'est pas dans l'unilatéralisme la
réponse n'est pas dans le retrait
unilatéral du disciple way et de la même
façon eh bien nous allons avec
la nouvelle mandature de la commission
européenne du parlement européen de la
commission européenne et bien travailler
au renforcement de nos outils
renforcement du règlement de 96 et puis
également faire en sorte que nous
affirmions tout simplement cette
puissance européenne nous n'avons pas
peur de revendiquer et bien que cet
espace de 500 millions d'habitants et de
consommateurs il doit peser encore et
toujours plus bastia disait il y à un
peu plus d'un siècle que là où le
commerce passe les frontières les
soldats ne la passe pas je crois que
quelques jours après avoir commémoré
dans l'unité et bien cette belle leçon
des alliés à l'été 44 et bien souvenons
nous que nous devons faire en sorte que
le commerce international puissent
assister à une désescalade détention
parce que ils menacent la stabilité tout
simplement merci
la parole est à madame la présidente
sophie primas république monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances a s'adresse donc à madame
la secrétaire d'état
ma question porte sur les turbulences
récentes mais forte que traverse le
groupe renault déjà ébranlé par
plusieurs mois de tensions la suite du
départ rocambolesque de carlos ghosn
l'alliance est de nouveau éprouvé par la
discussion pur leur très apparents ou
retrait réel vous nous direz d'une offre
de fusion faite par le groupe fiat
la compétitivité la conquête
d'opportunités de renault ont toujours
été au travers des différents
gouvernements une propre priorité
industriel et stratégique pour notre
pays aura un potentiel rapprochement
pour le moins précipitée avec fiat
n'aurait probablement pas rempli ses
objectifs
la proposition de fiat s'appuyait sur
une valorisation au rabais de renault
donne ait les coudées franches à la
famille agnelli dans une gouvernance
d'une nouvelle entité est divisé par
deux la part de l'état dans
l'actionnariat au delà de ce deal
enterré peut-être aussi soudainement
qu'il a été envisagé je souhaiterais que
vous nous éclaire y ait sur les
opportunités que vous pourriez encore
voir à cette éventuelle alliance entre
les deux constructeurs qui sont assez
similaires
deux constructeurs qui chasse souvent
sur les mêmes zones géographiques et sur
les mêmes gammes de voitures mais sur
les risques aussi en matière d'emploi de
gouvernance d'alliance pouvez vous nous
indiquer si vous poursuivez
officiellement ou pas avec le groupe
renault la discussion quelles seraient
vos conditions pour un accord et quelles
garanties vous pourriez demander enfin
il n'est pas impossible que ces
allers-retours avec fiat met en péril
l'alliance entre renault et nissan
la tiédeur denis salle devrait
d'ailleurs nous inviter à la prudence le
groupe japonais s'était abstenu je le
rappel du vote au sujet de la fusion
le ministre le maire s'est rendu au
japon la semaine dernière à l'occasion
du g20 finances pour tenter d'apaiser
les relations entre les deux groupes et
neeson qui tiendra le 25 juin prochain
son assemblée générale vient d'apprendre
par un courrier de renault que renault
s'opposait à la nouvelle gouvernance du
groupe japonais
comment entendons nous nous etat
actionnaire soutenir le groupe renault
pour sortir du blocage actuel et
rétablir un dialogue de qualité
constructif au sein de l'alliance je
vous remercie
on leur accorde la parole et à madame
agnès pas guéri nature secrète heures
près du xixe l'économie et des finances
de la ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice prima
d'abord je veux dire que comme vous le
savez lorsque
le groupe f cfa chrysler s'est présenté
à renault pour cette proposition
d'alliance l'état actionnaire de renault
à hauteur de 15 % l'a accueilli avec
ouverture et à travailler de manière
constructive et professionnelle avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes et je
crois que c'est ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre de tout actionnaire au
conseil d'administration de renault
nous avons été évidemment en plus
soucieux des intérêts stratégiques de
l'industrie automobile française bruno
le maire avait immédiatement fixé quatre
conditions préalables qui seront de
toute éternité nécessaire à réunir si
d'autres dossiers de cette nature ou
différents devait se présenter à
l'approbation de l'opération par l'état
la première condition c'est la
réalisation de cette opération dans le
cadre de l'alliance entre renault et
nissan et donc sans ambiguïté si nous
avons un partenaire stratégique ou si
renault un partenaire stratégique qui
est nissan
il convient que cette alliance soit
respectée et que chacun soit à l'aise
autour de la table du conseil
d'administration c'est aussi la clé de
la réussite des vrais projets
industriels la préservation des emplois
industriels et des sites industriels en
france deuxième condition une
gouvernance respectueuse des équilibres
de renault et de fc as et la
participation de ce futur ensemble
industriel à l'initiative des batteries
électriques engagé avec l'allemagne dans
cette initiative est également
primordial pour l'avenir de l'industrie
automobile européenne
je vais dire qu'ici que des progrès
significatifs avaient été faits sur les
3 premiers trois derniers éléments etc
et c'est la question d'un délai
additionnel pour s'assurer du soutien de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
notamment du soutien explicite de nissan
qui a amené fc as a retiré son offre
l'état prend acte de cette décision je
crois que nous n'avons pas à rougir
d'avoir posé ses conditions qui étaient
de bon sens de bon aloi et professionnel
je le redis pour la suite
bruno le maire était au japon ces
derniers jours il a vu avec son
homologue japonais monsieur c'est cauet
peux vous garantir l'attachement de la
france et du japon à l'alliance ce sujet
était bien à l'agenda et nous allons
progresser je vous remercie
mais si la parole est au président
jean-marc
abouti merci monsieur le président sur
le mans démocratique et social européen
avait la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre depuis plus de six mois
notre pays est confronté à une crise
sociale mais aussi une crise
territoriales
les deux ont des racines profondes et
des origines parfois anciennes la
sociologie du gilet jaune et les
résultats des dernières élections
européennes témoigne de cette double
fracture sociale et territoriale
le grand débat était l'occasion pour le
président de la république et pour le
gouvernement d'avoir une écoute
bienveillante et de renouer un dialogue
plus directe et plus approfondie avec
les élus locaux qui a suscité chez
beaucoup d'entre eux l'espoir d'être
enfin compris le président de la
république annoncé dès janvier confirme
en avril un nouvel acte de
décentralisation accompagnés d'une
révision ou adaptation la loi note et
d'une déconcentration des services de
l'état et cela dans un souci de
proximité d'efficacité et même
d'économie fin avril monsieur le premier
ministre vous annonciez pour le mois de
juin une étape de concertation sur la
déconcentration des décisions prises par
l'état et sur une nouvelle organisation
territoriale de l'état
mais jusqu'à présent rien de très
concret sur la décentralisation et la
révision de la loi neutre pourtant le
transfert de nouveaux blocs de
compétences des assouplissements dans
l'organisation des compétences entre
collectivités leurs établissements
d'intérêt communautaire ou encore la
différenciation territoriales sont des
sujets sur lesquels les élus locaux ont
de fortes attentes de mesures concrètes
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
vous indiquez sur ce volet
décentralisation et collectivités
locales
le périmètre les grandes orientations la
méthode et le calendrier envisagé par le
gouvernement pour engager cette réforme
est essentielle pour nos territoires
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre en
charge de la ville et du logement vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gars
boutique je vous prie d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser l'absence de madame la
ministre jacqueline gourault qui est
retenu à l'assemblée nationale sur le
projet de loi relatif aux compétences de
la collectivité européenne d'alsace vous
l'avez dit est très parfaitement dit les
derniers mois que nous avons vécues ont
mis en avant à la fois les inquiétudes
sociales mais également les inquiétudes
territoriale et à l'issue de ce grand
débat national
le président de la république s'est
engagé sur deux éléments très importants
le premier s'est consolidée l'exercice
des mandats locaux et en particulier les
mandats des mers et le deuxième c'est
d'ouvrir un nouvel acte de
décentralisation
alors pour répondre concrètement à votre
question il y aura deux projets de lois
qui vont être présentés
s'agissant de l'engagement des élus
locaux ce projet de loi sera présenté
dans les toutes prochaines semaines par
sébastien lecornu
l'objectif de ce projet loin c'est à la
fois d'encourager cet engagement cet
engagement vis-à-vis des élus locaux
cet engagement au niveau local mais
c'est aussi de faciliter le quotidien
des élus locaux où c'est encore de les
remercier et de leur témoigner toute la
considération que la république leur
doit bien évidemment et ce projet de loi
il vise donc être présenté dans les
toutes prochaines semaines en conseil
des ministres pour une adoption avant
les élections municipales de 2020 le
premier ministre aura l'occasion de
détailler le contenu de ce projet de loi
très prochainement il inclura bien les
irritants liés à la boyne l'autre comme
nous les dénommons
et que vous les connaissez très bien le
second projet de loi il sera cette fois
ci consacré à la décentralisation il
sera présenté par madame la ministre
jacqueline gourault en ciblant les
politiques du quotidien l'objectif de
cette décentralisation et de rapprocher
la décision publique de nos concitoyens
si je prends un exemple qui est la
politique du logement
évidemment qu'il faut plus décentralisée
la politique du logement
parce que c'est lorsque vous élisez
votre mère que vous vous demandez si ce
dernier peut impacter votre politique du
logement
et lorsque vous voyez que la politique
entre ou encore trop conduite par des
zonages vous dites que cette
décentralisation est importante
sega voter oui merci monsieur le
ministre il ya quelques mois seulement
nous avons été un petit peu échaudé par
une loi sur l'eau et l'assainissement
avec un assouplissement a minima en
forme de report d'échéances qui a laissé
un goût amer au sénat j'espère qu'à
l'avenir les positions du gouvernement
prenant mieux en compte le principe de
subsidiarité tel qu'il a été défini par
le président de la république lorsqu'il
déclarait en début d'année je crois que
l'on a besoin de remettre de la
responsabilité au plus près du terrain
merci la parole collègue jean sol pour
le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame buzyn vous n'êtes pas sans
ignorer que les services d'urgence des
hôpitaux français en proie à une crise
profonde depuis de nombreuses années
sont aujourd'hui à bout de souffle il y
à 12 ans déjà un rapport de notre haute
assemblée les décrivez comme le miroir
grossissant des dysfonctionnement de
l'ensemble de notre système de santé
madame la ministre que vous aviez
annoncé dès votre prise de fonction
pendant ce problème à bras le corps
mais qu'en est il réellement force est
de constater que la situation s'aggrave
et s'amplifie de jour en jour face à
l'inadéquation entre le nombre de
passages les moyens alloués et la
disponibilité des lits d'aval
malgré les nombreux plans déjà mises en
place ou annoncés on ne peut que
constater leur inefficacité chronique
résultat les personnels de santé d
urgence multiplient les mouvements de
grève sur tout notre territoire
peut-on les blâmer au vu des chiffres et
de la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
certainement pas en vingt ans les
urgences ont vu leur fréquentation
doubler nos personnels sont confrontés
chaque jour à la multiplication des
agressions tant verbales que physiques
car qui dit saturation des services dit
exaspération des patients et épuisement
des personnels soignants qui se sentent
délaissés
nos professionnels de santé réclament à
juste titre davantage de moyens humains
et financiers
alors vous me répondrez certainement que
la loi santé votée à l'assemblée
nationale et en cours de délibération au
sénat pour te la double ambition de
mieux répartir à l'accès aux soins et de
libérer les établissements hospitaliers
sous tension mais les mesures annoncées
ne devrait voir le jour qu'en 2022
ce sera déjà trop tard il y a urgence
madame la ministre pour nos urgences
nous ne pouvons plus attendre car nous
parlons ici de notre bien le plus
précieux la santé des français mais
aussi celle de nos personnels de santé
qui n'en peuvent plus tant physiquement
que psychologiquement alors ma question
est simple
quelles mesures d'urgence allez vous
initier pour éviter que d'autres drames
surviennent pour agir enfin et pour
faire face à cet enjeu majeur de santé
publique qui sous votre responsabilité
pour vous répondre la parole et komlan
families la santé les solidarités
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sol évidemment vous avez raison
le système est en tension depuis de
nombreuses années et l'augmentation du
nombre de passages aux urgences n'a fait
qu'aggraver les choses
j'ai souhaité accompagner les hôpitaux
cette année avec un dégel particulier
avec un refinancement de 300 millions
dès le mois de mars et 700 millions
d'euros supplémentaires donnés aux
hôpitaux qui d'ailleurs ont réduit leur
déficit cette année ont également réduit
leur dette toxique et donc j'essaye
d'accompagner au mieux les hôpitaux qui
sont le plus en difficulté j'ai souhaité
dans les mesures d'urgence que j'ai
annoncé au congrès annuel des
urgentistes que ces crédits nouveaux
soit fléché particulièrement vers des
services d'urgence
en réalité la situation est très
variable d'un service à l'autre et les
besoins sont variables d'un service à
l'autre
dans certains cas il manque des médecins
dans d'autres cas plutôt des
professionnels paramédicaux dans
d'autres cas les locaux sont extrêmement
vétustes et trop petit pour accueillir
le flux de malades et donc il faut
pouvoir donner à chaque hôpital à chaque
site
la réponse appropriée j'ai donc demandé
aux agences régionales de santé
d'accompagner les hôpitaux en tension
certains ne le sont pas il ya beaucoup
de services d'urgence en france qui
fonctionne avec moins de quinze mille
passages par an c'est à dire moins de
deux passages par heure et donc il faut
aussi être attentif à ce que les budgets
à accompagner des sites les plus en
difficulté c'est ce que nous allons
faire dans les semaines qui viennent
j'annoncerai au delà de la mission
nationale donnée au président du conseil
national des urgences hospitalières le
professeur pierre carli et aux députés
même thomas meunier de repenser notre
système d'urgence pour le refonder
j'annoncerai très concrètement comment
cette offre d'accompagnement va aller
vers les établissements et aller vers
les professionnels
je ne néglige pas leur charge de travail
elle est à la fois physique et nous le
savons vous comme moi parce que vous
êtes un professionnel de santé aussi
elle est aussi émotionnel aux arômes aux
urgences c'est extrêmement difficile
effectivement de
soutenir toutes les personnes en très
grande difficultés émotionnelles
cela rajoute de la surcharge et je ne
néglige pas ce point dans
l'accompagnement qui leur sera apportée
je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant l'autre
collègue maurice antiste pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain de la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à l'ensemble du gouvernement
la france compte plus de 1,3 million de
jeunes qui ne sont ni à l'école ni à
l'université ni en apprentissage et ni
en emploi
concernant l'outre-mer et
particulièrement la martinique
l'apprentissage est rendu encore plus
difficile en raison du tissu économique
principalement constituée de
micro-entreprises sakhir l'accueil
d'apprentis très difficile et maintient
les jeunes et leurs familles dans
l'angoissé et le doute permanent pour
être totalement transparent
mais chez les ministres je suis
sollicité toutes les semaines par des
jeunes martiniquais et leur famille
qu'ils fassent allait dispensable
nécessité d'une alternance ne trouvent
pas d'entreprise et sont contraints
d'abandonner leurs études
d'ailleurs si on prend en compte
l'ensemble de la petite de l'alternance
apprentissage et professionnalisation
on observe une baisse des effectifs de
4,1 pour cent par rapport à février 2018
la réforme de l'apprentissage voulue par
le gouvernement qui s'accompagne de la
mise en place d'un nouveau statut de
l'apprenti théorique mois plus attractif
pour les jeunes ne semble pas faire
consensus localement principalement
parce que la condition aux crises
requises pour obtenir la
prépa-apprentissage sont identiques à
celles de l'apprentissage lui-même
nécessité d'obtenir un contrat
d'apprentissage
quid donc des jeunes qui n'arriveront
pas à trouver de contrat de travail dans
le cadre de ce nouveau dispositif
une enquête de studyrama révèle ainsi
que 84% des sondés entre le bac et bac +
on trouvait la recherche d'une
entreprise très difficile
je souhaite donc connaître les
intentions du gouvernement en la matière
pour nos jeunes les ultramarins qui se
sentent totalement abandonnée pour vous
répondre la parole est dans la
secrétaire d'état a pas de problème
l'iffor parole du gouvernement madame si
belhanda président pardon monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
mesdames les sénatrices pardon messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
antiste je souhaite évidemment excusé
l'absence de la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud qui est actuellement à
genève aux côtés du président de la
république où il participe au centenaire
de l'organisation internationale du
travail
je vous remercie pour votre question qui
met évidemment en lumière les
difficultés particulières relatives à
l'emploi à l'insertion professionnelle
et plus largement à la formation des
jeunes en particulier dans les outre mer
est évidemment vous l'avez souligné en
martinique
je partage avec vous le constat d'un
chômage qui frappe plus durement non
seulement les jeunes mais également les
territoires d'outre-mer par rapport au
reste du pays
ce constat cette difficulté nous la
connaissons évidemment et nous avons
souhaité agir depuis le début du
quinquennat pour y apporter des réponses
vous vous en souvenez sans doute le
livre bleu des outre mer en 2018 avait
fléché 700 millions du 700 millions
d'euros du programme d'investissement
dans les compétences spécifiquement pour
les outre-mer apportant ainsi un soutien
fort à la formation professionnelle qui
est un vecteur de reprise d'emploi
nous avons également en avril 2019
étendu le dispositif des emplois france
où l'autorité de muriel pénicaud annick
girardin et julien de normandie et sur
le sujet plus spécifique de
l'apprentissage
partout sur le territoire nous avons une
augmentation du nombre de jeunes en
apprentissage mais les chiffres que nous
avons dans les outre mer et en
martinique en particulier ne sont pas
satisfaisants c'est la raison pour
laquelle une ordonnance spécifique
découlant de la loi pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel sera
dédié aux outre mer cette ordonnance a
été largement concertée la concertation
continue encore aujourd'hui avec les
élus locaux à la fois pour pour bâtir un
diagnostic mais également des solutions
elle précisera les règles de gouvernance
et de déploiement dans les outre-mer des
dispositifs relatifs à l'apprentissage
je veux vous assurer monsieur le
sénateur de notre préoccupation
constante sur ce sujet et dans notre
volonté de développer l'apprentissage
également dans les autres mers je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue je suis une guide est pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès de monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances mes chers
collègues depuis vendredi dernier un
scandale alimentaire un de plus secoue
notre pays celui des steaks hachés de
très mauvaise qualité distribués aux
plus démunis cette affaire est choquant
à double titre d'abord car elle
constitue une faute morale est tolérable
en vison nos concitoyens se trouvant en
situation de précarité aussi parce
qu'elle constitue une fraude une
tromperie sur la qualité des produits
achetés
les médias l'ont rappelé plusieurs
acteurs sont intervenus dans cette
chaîne que je qualifierais de
particulièrement longue
le fonds européen d'aidé aux plus
démunis qui soutenait financièrement les
états de l'union
l'état qui a confié à grimmer
l'organisation d'un appel d'offres puis
enfin une entreprise financière retenu
pour le marché mais qui s'appuie sur une
autre entreprise polonais cette fois ci
pour son approvisionnement en viande
en outre ce qui demeure regrettable
c'est que seul le prix a été retenu
comme critère dans cet appel d'offres
d'ailleurs je m'interroge comment en
faisant le ratio entre le prix total
d'achat et le poids de la viande vendue
celui ci n'a pas appelé l'attention des
pouvoirs publics
ainsi monsieur le ministre l'état ne
devrait il pas mieux
c'est la prise en compte du critère lié
à la qualité dans l'attribution de ces
marchés par ailleurs alors que l'on
parle de plus en plus de circuits courts
ne conviendrait-il pas là aussi d'en
faire une véritable règles européennes
dans l'organisation de cette mise en
concurrence
au nom du bon sens écologique économique
et solidaire pour vous répondre la
parole à madame la secrétaire et après
l'humilité économie et des finances
avaient la part eau merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice guide est
ce donc
la dgccrf a effectivement annoncé
vendredi matin avoir découvert une
tromperie sur la qualité des steaks
hachés distribué par une entreprise
française à des associations de soutien
aux plus démunis jeu d'abord être même
sur deux points
c'est une affaire qui est le fait d'
escroc cynique qui pensaient pouvoir
agir en toute impunité
c'est raté il ya eu des contrôles ils
seront renvoyés devant le procureur et
je vous le dis très clairement
le deuxième élément est devant le
procureur une fraude c'est deux ans de
prison et 1 5 million d'euros d'amendé
c'est la peine qui est encouru donc les
choses sont claires le deuxième point
important est qu'il s'agit d'un sujet
tromperie mais pas un sujet de santé je
le redis car c'est aussi important et
c'est pour ça que nous avons fait cette
transparence de rassurer sur les
éléments de faits exacts qui se sont
passées c'est pour cela que nous avons
souhaité aussi faire preuve de la plus
grande transparence parce que c'est une
façon d'envoyer un message aux
entreprises en question en disant
qu'elle ne continueront pas à faire leur
petite marche discrètement et qu'elles
seront systématiquement sanctionnés je
veux également revenir sur les faits
d'abord ce sont les associations qui ont
été extrêmement réactif puisque dès
qu'elles ont constaté que la marchandise
ne correspondait pas au cahier des
charges
elle nous ou non signalées elles ont
suspendu la distribution elles nous ont
permis de faire l'enquète le tout à bas
bruit puisqu'il fallait réunir un
ensemble de preuves pour pouvoir faire
cette transmission procureur la deuxième
chose c'est que cette marchandise elle
est achetée dans le cadre d'un cahier
des charges très précis sinon on
pourrait pas qualifier une tromperie par
construction donc ce n'est pas seulement
le sujet du prix qui est dans le cahier
des charges mais vous avez une
description de la marchandise et ensuite
un prix si on vous dit que
cegid acheter une veste verte de telle
taille avec telle caractéristique vous
avez exactement la description de la
marchandise donc il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté sur ce point enfin nous
avons nous allons travailler avec les
trois services qui sont engagés
ministère de l'agriculture et ministère
de la santé qui ont marché main dans la
main pour faire en sorte que cette
fraude soit traitée donc nous allons en
tirer les conséquences y compris par les
assauts des pro les associations
nouvelles et des stocks
et je peux vous assuré nous agirons avec
la même fermeté dans tous les cas qui
pourraient se présenter un business très
bien nous en avons terminé avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
les prochaines auront lieu le jeu qui va
juin à 15 heures
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
merci je vais suspendre la séance
jusqu'à 18 heures 10 elle reprendra pour
les explications des votes des groupes
puis le scrutin solennel son projet de
loi relatif à l'organisation la
transformation du système de santé
la séance des suspendus jusqu à 18h10
et voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du sénat au gouvernement une
séance marquée largement par la crise
des services d'urgence dans les hôpitaux
français plusieurs sénateurs ont
interpellé la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn sur cette crise
pour le sénateur la république en marche
michel amiel il n'y a pas de solution
miracle à cette crise à moyens constants
pour la communiste cathy apourceau poly
le gouvernement fait preuve de non
assistance à personne en danger
et puis pour le sénateur socialiste jean
louis tourenne le projet de loi santé
qui a été débattue la semaine dernière
au sénat est une réforme est je cite qui
n'aura pas d'effet sur la crise des
services d'urgence alors la ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn n'a pas du tout
apprécié cette expression de réformettes
et elle a appelé les élus socialistes
qui ont été au pouvoir à faire preuve
d'humilité alors qu'ils n'ont selon elle
va améliorer la situation de l'hôpital
lorsqu'il était au pouvoir
et puis agnès buzyn a également rappelé
les mesures qu'elle entendait mettre en
oeuvre à court terme pour résoudre cette
crise des services d'urgence les
personnels urgentistes vont bénéficier
d'une augmentation de primes les
bâtiments vétustes des services
d'urgence vont être rénovés et puis le
du personnel sera recruté dans les
services d'urgences qui sont
actuellement sous tension puis les
sénateurs ont observé une minute de
silence à la mémoire des trois
sauveteurs mort vendredi en mer aux
sables d'olonne alors qu'il se pourrait
un marin pêcheur en détresse les
sénateurs vendéens ont exprimé leur
émotion face à ce drame le premier
ministre edouard philippe s'est
également associé à cette minute de
silence et puis il a souhaité faire part
de sa volonté de faire évoluer le modèle
économique des marins sauveteurs qui est
actuellement basé en large partie sur
les dons et sur le bénévolat et puis
lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité le gouvernement a donné des
précisions sur les solutions qu'il
propose est à la fracture territoriale
une fracture qui s'est révélée qui a été
révélée par la crise des gilet jaune il
y aura donc deux projets de loi d'abord
un projet de loi de décentralisation
pour donner davantage de pouvoirs au
maire et aux citoyens dans la décision
et puis un projet de loi pour faciliter
le quotidien des maires et les
encourager à l'engagement quotidien
communal un projet de loi qui sera
adoptée quelques mois avant les
élections municipales
merci beaucoup alexandre bouffard pour
toutes ces précisions c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi demain pas de senna à 360 noms se
retrouvent jeudi édition spéciale dès 9
heures sur l'antenne de public sénat
pour le discours de politique générale
d'edouard philippe devant à la haute
assemblée très bonne suite des
programmes et à geelong
[Musique]